and it is of course time for the press
preview our first look at the front
pages
as they arrive over the remainder of the
hour we'll be taking a look at what's
making the headlines
without mckell voice senior editor at
the economist and humor print editor for
the guardians
g1 to those two in just a second but
let's take you through the front pages
that we have
and you may detect a bit of a theme at
furious william
uh the headline here at the duke of
cambridge's reaction to the bbc
investigation into journalist martin
beshear the lead story
for the guardian
the bbc's lies fueled my mother's
paranoia at the times
leading with the same story
australia's biggest beef exporter has
told the ft it could increase uk sales
tenfold if the pm
agrees a no tariff zero quarter trade
deal
uh with the country
afraid that's your lot uh i'm calvin
hume you're joining us
to take you through the couple of papers
that we have and we were just
good very good evening to both of you
who were just commenting when we were
all there
lots of news around but often when there
is lots of news around that means that
people working in the offices that you
guys work in are generally a hard
attitude so
let's start this evening too shall we
with them with the guardian uh your
paper they're taking all of this
deceitful and damaging everyone i am
of course leaping on the statements the
incredibly emotive statements
from princess william and harry
yeah neil this is the thing you spend
all day um
looking at the lord dyson's report and
thinking that that
looking at the severity of that and the
language he uses
and thinking that things couldn't get
any more serious than that and then
these statements as you say drop um late
evening
um and the language in them as you say
absolutely uh extraordinary
uh the accusations that are made um
williams saying that he felt that
what the baby did species did fueled his
mother's paranoia
um i think we were all pretty shocked at
just uh how
emotional those statements were um
and i think they're going to cause some
serious problems for the bbc i think
that
they would have known this was going to
be a difficult day for them but i think
these statements
uh taken together will mean that they're
going to have a
difficult few days and maybe a different
few weeks yeah i think so i mean and
i mean william's statement did conclude
with the fact that you know
investigative journalists were the ones
that brought this to light however both
he and his brother
make a direct link between the deceit
the use of lord spencer to to secure
this
interview you know and their mother's
eventual death
that's right i mean of course we must
remember to put it in context the
the idea that there are links between
the way that the media and parts of the
media behaved and particularly the
paparazzi not only the
the british paparazzi but those beyond
were in some way
driving events that led to the death of
diana i think the big difference tonight
is that that has spread
and there is i think an acceptance at
the top of the bbc and certainly from
tim davey the director general
that it is fair to bring the bbc into
that frame
and the way that it is being brought
into it is really a story which is not
only something happened a very long time
ago which was i must say it was my
initial response when this story
surfaced but really what has happened
since and why did so many people keep
silent since many people
who've held very high positions were
very respected
very proven journalists and editorial
leaders
at the bbc and have then gone on often
to other
big jobs and rather sort of grand jobs
in the rest of british public life
they knew about this and i think that is
the really painful thing
certainly it is for me i i know that
journalists can
certainly not see green incorruptables
and you shouldn't look down on
others who've you know who've sort of
come a cropper over difficult stories
but this does seem to rather let down
the whole ethos of the bbc i think
that's what's so disappointing
i mean hugh for those who don't work in
our profession just just put into some
kind of context that the
the abuse of of process the the the
failure of journalistic standards
that martin beshear and those who who
covered this up
participated in well it's an
extraordinary
thing in that um forged documents
we all we'll want to investigate things
we all want to bring
um things to light and to some extent in
our profession we're all ambitious as
well and certainly
uh martin bashir was ambitious but
there are lines that we all draw um
and to go to the lengths that he did
whereby he
was having bank statements drawn up that
he then
used as leverage if you like to win
people's confidence
to get them to introduce him uh to other
people and to get him ultimately
uh to to steiner so
you can't completely fabricate documents
um
journalists do you know journalists
within uh their investigations
do sometimes uh uh result of some
practices that you don't have to be able
to justify in the public interest but
there was never a kind of public
interest
um to resort to those kinds of uh
maneuvers
uh to get this kind of story um i think
that he
even within newsrooms people were
absolutely astonished
um to see how far he'd gone
i'm just going to get uh our gallery to
show our viewers that the front page of
the times and their headlines a direct
quote from
the duke of cambridge the bbc's lies
fueled my mother's paranoia i mean i was
chatting to our royal correspondent
earlier this evening and
you know we were both struck by the tone
and the emotion given their position but
are we perhaps guilty of forgetting the
fact these were two boys
who lost their mother at a really young
age
i mean would any of us react any
differently and perhaps
would any of us react what we'd all
react perhaps more intemperately
than the what the prince's have in
response to to the findings of the dyson
review
well that is in itself a sign of how
much times have changed isn't it i think
you're right to point out that
people will draw their own conclusions
about how they would react to revelation
like this
but there was an expectation that being
a member of the royal family
meant that you you put stuff away you
kept it under wraps you didn't let
the old saying was you didn't let
daylight in on magic
that is clearly being busted open a
number of times uh recently not
least very dramatically by that meghan
markle prince harry interview
and everything that followed in prince
harry's recent remarks about his
upbringing
and how he he feels in a sense that he
was failed by the royal institution and
by parenting
so it's very interesting also to see
that
uh the duke of cambridge prince william
is also embracing emotional language
he's often seen as the more level-headed
of the two brothers he is the ultimate
next in line after prince charles to the
throne
so it's a bigger deal for him to use
this language
but clearly as you suggest the two boys
do feel that lots of
things have come home to roost from so
many years ago
that perhaps they were expected simply
to suffer in silence or tell those close
to them
but not to bring into the public domain
and i think the problem here
is that that has happened the vector for
this has been
the bbc and that martin beshear's
behavior as he tried
to get the scoops that he wanted it was
definitely interesting to the public but
it's very hard to mount a public
interest defense
for it in terms of legally or morally
i think it's interesting neil the
statements are quite different in that
the williams statement is very
specifically about bbc he mainly
references the bbc directly
on many occasions where harry's
statement is much broader
and it seems if you get to the end of it
that harry trying to almost to pull
together
all of the reporting all of their uh
those grievances about the way the press
behaved towards their
their mother in general um and so
clearly they have a common anger tonight
but they've expressed it in a slightly
different way with nobody says something
about them as people
oh there's a really good point if i
could just come and come back well you
said i think
what prince william said is really
institutional and that is
a problem for the bbc i did an awful lot
of work for the bbc i'm a great admirer
of the bbc i think it upholds
some fantastic just so it's interrupted
sorry center uptown but just on that
point he's right to call it out was my
my point it is an institutional attack
really by
the next book one air to the throne on
the major british broadcasting
well that that's the point i mean if we
take a look at the express again they
have focused on
william and and and the link to the bbc
look
you know people in glass boxes shouldn't
throw stones news organizations
make mistakes but whenever there's been
discussion of diana in the past it's
been the treatment that she received
at the hands of the red tops the
tabloids the paparazzi and so on
as you say this is the state broadcaster
and i don't want to criticize another
news organization but whether the bbc
now
well i did if that question was to me i
i would quibble at the phrase state
broadcasting we don't have state
broadcast it's a publicly
funded broadcast it's not a state
broadcast in the sense that
many states around the world have an
authoritarian state broadcaster but
nonetheless it's
very very important and it upholds
public service
broadcasting at the uk in its heart and
in the wider world let's not forget this
isn't just a british story this is
really much about the
the bbc and it's it's international
reach yes i think that is difficult
you've seen that the president bbc
management and new director general in
tim davey have
some hesitation about when to uh the
panorama but it got aired within the
week so that happened
um so clearly there is embarrassment
about this a desire
to have it all aired and to have it over
with
the problem i think it leaves is what
has happened in all those years since
where's the accountability
for what happened in those years since
and why was the decision made in 2016
to bring martian bashir who obviously i
mean
you might have thoughts about this as
well it does seem very hard to
understand
why he was i do think that was the
extraordinary to bring him back
and given all the the the misgivings
that there have been
uh about him before um and i i think
that's
one of the questions that that would be
leveled at them i mean to some extent
there's been a strategy here of saying
look can we draw a line tim davies whole
stresses and saying can we draw a line
under it
and move on many of the people who were
there then aren't there that now
um and you quite could excuse past
misbehavior but when you then get into
the cover-up
you're almost in watergate territory and
it's not the the substance of the uh
the original sin is the cover-up that
the problem
um and that's what people say well can
you assure us that the institution is
such now that there would never be this
kind of cover-up
i think that's what makes it
contemporaneous and in a way that's what
makes it so toxic in the days to come
hugh and we must pause there for just a
second
we'll return to you after the break but
of course at the moment we're expecting
a
statement from the white house uh about
a potential a
peace deal in the middle east uh we'll
be discussing that and much more after
this
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
[Music]
please just make their first move and
they're following firing
again
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansung
that's what's left of the north tunnel
uh where the north koreans exploded
five nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
[Music]
shrapnel from that explosion so you can
see it littered along
all the way we take you to the heart of
the stories that shape our world train
station the airport they're both
closed we're not sure about the roads
we've seen reports that they are being
blocked by police so we're going to try
and find
a way out
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance
we help you understand the world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview and
hugh continuing to take you through the
papers um
and we'll return to the guardian and uh
frankly perhaps
on any other day one suspects that this
may well have been the lead story the
the talk of a ceasefire between israel
and hamas
what do you make of this i mean clearly
there has been some work behind the
scenes the egyptians have clearly been
being instrumental in whatever happens
however we are all once again on
tenterhooks to see whether or not
the ceasefire actually starts and holds
well that that's one thing you're
certainly right this would have i think
being a much more prominent story there
on the front page of
one of the serious newspapers had it not
been for that bbc
story i think there are a number of
angles here aren't there one is
that the ceasefire was coming why did it
take
so long i think there obviously there's
criticism of president biden there did
he move
too slowly there is also of course
calculation and there is a strategy
behind when you
go for a ceasefire if you're one of the
the big movers in this story as america
undoubtedly is for over all of the
criticism
it gets it it is in there and it has to
be in there for
for anything like a ceasefire to take
hold so
it wasn't the case that america was
really waiting until the israeli defense
forces had
had said like we've done what we feel
that we need to do against hamas and now
we can
stop and if so what does that mean does
it mean that this is
preparation for a negotiation for a
ceasefire that will really hold
or is it simply that you simply stop the
sort of terrible violence that we've
seen in the cycle that we've seen this
week we don't really yet know but it'd
be very interesting the words that
president biden chooses
when he comes out to make the statement
imminently expected
how does he frame the expectations
around that
i mean hugh we look at what has happened
over the over the past 11 days and
people talk about disproportionality and
use of violence and the availability of
western bulk material and all the rest
of it but
there is there is a certain frustration
amongst some people that we are in a
washroom's repeat situation
when it comes to the israel-palestine
situation
and until someone tries something
different we are going to be here again
it is just a question of when
and i think people have been looking to
president biden to get some sense as to
whether or not he will be the person
uh who will break that sequence and i
think that's why i'm
really disappointed in his statements up
until yesterday when he seemed to
change his tone slightly and and say
look you've really got to
um to de-escalate this bombing but up
until then it is almost if he had been
facilitating it by his enact um and one
of the things you
one of the ways in which you judge an
american president is really and how
they deal with
uh the question of israel and palestine
america has huge
influence there we know that and it's
really about how they choose to
to use that president trump chose it to
use it in a particular way
and people who wish president biden well
were looking to see that he
would use it in a more judicious way and
have been quite disappointed up until
now so
he really does people want to see some
sign
of him really gripping that issue now
and and using america's influence in a
goodbye
i mean i suppose when we always come
back to the same point i mean the
strategic of
the strategic significance of israel at
times does seem to trump you know
basic humanitarian concerns president
biden
as we say we're waiting to hear what he
has to say about all of this but
you know the united states isn't the
world's policeman anymore is it
it hasn't been for a while well it isn't
but i mean
it sounds sometimes people want to have
that argument both ways they want to say
america's not the world's policeman then
they want to blame america
for upholding and supplying and in the
end being a big
supporter both practically militarily
the state of israel so
in a sense it's involved whether or not
you think it
it should be one thing i would say is
it's very early in the biden presidency
you don't can't choose the time that
this kind of crisis
breaks out my guess is that president
biden who is very experienced in these
matters
he's been around for a lot of time he's
been vice president
he has dealt with this this as you say
the
terrible sort of cycle of rinse and
repeat has
come about a number of times he knows
about it i imagine that what he wants to
do these events have
played out quite fast this week yes
there have been a high number of
casualties but it's been a relatively
short amount of time i think what he
wants to do is get a ceasefire done
and then sit down and work out what
happens next unless you
thought you were electing a president it
was going to come in hot and heavy
saying i've got a plan for a peace
process when the warring parties are in
no way ready to come to the
negotiating table if he played that card
and failed he would also look very weak
and hugh i'm afraid we must leave it